moi je ne suis pas ministre de
l'éducation nationale mais je dirais
peut mieux faire si je vais un bulletin
de notes à un vampire
par principe je suis quelqu'un de
constructif donc je vois plutôt toujours
les choses positives et nous avons un
discours encourageant
néanmoins un court terme il est décevant
il est décevant parce que nous n'avons
pas les réponses que nous attendions sur
les mineurs non accompagnés que
j'appelle moi les jeunes migrants les
prendre en charge simplement jusqu'à
leur évaluation de la minorité n'est pas
suffisant car aujourd'hui l'état le fait
pendant cinq jours là il le fera pendant
peut-être dix à quinze jours mais
pendant une année ou deux années c'est
nous qui auront la charge totale
or il faut même si c'est notre vision
que nous soyons aider dans ce dispositif
et puis sur les ayes ce n'est pas
convenable
nous devons absolument avancer plus que
cela alors certes on peut mettre en
place d'un groupe de travail
on peut discuter mais j'entends qu'au
bout de cinq mois on ne peut pas tout
régler mais on n'attendra pas une année
de plus et moi je crois que le
gouvernement doit maintenant avancer
concrètement dans les réponses que nous
attendons